madame li na webber oui m janvier
huissier de justice
on a tous une mère quelquefois on aime
trop et parfois pas assez
parfois elle nous fait honte et souvent
elle fait n'importe quoi et ben non
alors certes il doit faire quoi ça
vendre je contacte tottenham
on a tous une mère mais vous connaissez
pas la mienne ça va qu'est ce que tu
fais là c'est ma mère il le vrai beauté
du nord presque vikings moi la grosse
vache hollandaise elle est comment j'ai
jamais dit qu'elle était moche j'ai dit
qu'elle était un peu forte
il est qu'ils sont faux ils étaient
personnes et abandonné à l'anglais
recueillies et a fait officiellement non
pas du tout
[Musique]
et toi tu es complètement folle
on ne dit pas tu es folle à sa mère si
je comprends bien là ton plan s'adresse
au nez chez un narcotrafiquant qui
taille mais sur une plage dans les
années on va savoir est une femme
exceptionnelle
pourquoi tu m'a amené ici la demo la
vérité oui ce mec-là alvaro c'est mon 21
on a tous une mère on se construit
autour d'elle là où il ya de la place
enfin là où il en reste un peu
et ont fini par grandir à côté d'une
énigme au congrès sutra jamais puis un
jour on les regarde comme des femmes
qu'on aurait croisé dans nos vies et
qu'on pourrait aimer simplement pour ce
qu'elles sont ben alors parce que vous
êtes pauvres nouvelle est la police et
les belges